was talking this woman after a show she
was probably mid-40s very attractive and
uh lived in texas and she was saying
some kind of weird [ __ ] to me at one
point she said gay marriage is not real
and i was like i'm pretty sure it's real
i've seen it before but
it's like it's not real because i can't
procreate so it's not real and i'm like
okay
and we kept drinking and then finally i
tried to make out with her and she goes
i'm married i was like yeah you're
mid-40s so it's not real
and i don't hate gay people i'm pro-gay
people man i i protested for gay
marriage i believe very strongly in gay
marriage i i believe if you're a person
who's watching this special right now
and you don't believe in gay marriage
turn it off you're a [ __ ] dick and i
don't want anything to do here now
and
my reasoning is so simple right if you
don't believe in gay marriage you're a
[ __ ] because
it's got nothing to [ __ ] do with you
right doesn't matter it doesn't matter
who loves who or who wants to be with
who it's out of your [ __ ] business
none of your [ __ ] business if you
hate gay marriage you know what you
should do
don't marry a gay person
that'll be your little way of getting
around it that'll [ __ ] show the guys
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
i like to be gay i they [ __ ] suit me
i'm this i studied musical theater at
university
i'm wearing leather without a shirt
underneath
[Applause]
i would love to be gay i tell you why
because i'm a man's man
i like men
men like me
we like each other
i hate women
women hate me
we hate each other
the only reason i couldn't be gay is
because i could never [ __ ] a man
because i could never [ __ ] something
that i respect
[Applause]
that's a good [ __ ] joke hey how's it
going
everybody's mad about something
recently i got attacked online by some
gay bloggers and it hurt my feelings
i have no problem with gay people but i
[ __ ] hate bloggers
i'm not saying it because this person
was gay they was acting like a [ __ ]
online it was like mischaracterizing my
jokes trying to make a point off of me
when it was really it's like yo i'm your
ally [ __ ] i'm not trying to stop
gay people i got better [ __ ] to do this
[ __ ] was saying things to try to
get gay people to beat me up
seriously he was like dave chappelle's
jokes i don't know how he actually talks
when he's making his voice up
david chappelle's jokes
were an affront to the manhood of all
gay men
what the [ __ ] does that mean i didn't
say anything that would allude to gay
men not being men i know you meant
in fact what could be manlier
than [ __ ] another guy in the ass
it's the most gangster [ __ ] i've ever
heard of in my life
first of all i'll tell you right now
what i said uh and i will tell you that
this was not a joke it's a true story
and i just happened to tell it all right
what happened was i went to a gallery
party all right i don't know who in here
has ever been rich before but these are
very nice parties
uh you know wine and cheese and ball of
conversation
and there was a few eccentric types one
of which was a very wealthy man that
happened to be wearing a dress i don't
know what you called me this is a [ __ ]
or drag queen perhaps whatever it was
was definitely a man
and this man was definitely on drugs i
don't know what kind of drugs he's on
but i knew he had too much he didn't
look good
just like this he's like ah he looks
sick and all his friends were standing
around him concerned trying to revive
him i don't know whether he looked like
some kind of gay cpr just fanning and
[ __ ]
[Applause]
i saw all this from a distance now i
should have minded my own business but i
got curious i was like
and i went over there all i said i said
excuse me gentlemen gentlemen
is he okay
and then they looked at me like i was
evil
she is fine
i'm sorry to know this is what we were
doing um
here's my
thing i support anybody's right to be
whoever they feel like they are inside i
mean ally in that
however
my question is
to what degree do i have to participate
in your self-image
is it fair that i have to change my
whole pronoun game up for this
[ __ ] that didn't make sense
seriously
if i put on an argyle sweater and i'm
like hey everybody i feel like a white
guy in the sweater and i want some
goddamn respect in a bank loan that's
not gonna work
give a [ __ ] out i feel why should i go
[ __ ] how you feel [ __ ] is a pronoun
but there was no time for philosophical
debate this was an emergency situation
i said fine sorry guys i was just
worried because
because she looks terrible
she just fell off the bench
appears that her dick is popping out of
her dress
no matter if i call an ambulance champ
i'd rather not be at a party where
[ __ ] od there's too many questions to
answer
[Applause]
okay i've been through this before i had
a friend from high school now in high
school this guy was a thug wheel right
he was a [ __ ] dope boy he did it all
he's a wild dude people used to be very
scared of him and then after high school
word on the street was he'd come out the
closet i personally didn't believe it
i bring him up because last year
he calls me out of the blue like yo
what's up man i got your number from
so-and-so and i heard you gonna be in
new york doing a show could i get some
tickets i was like [ __ ] yeah get some
tickets man how you been he said well
we'll catch up at the show man but yo
i'm appreciate i'll see you soon i said
all right man take care and i was about
to hang up and i couldn't resist i was
just like
hey [ __ ] i heard you was gay what's
going on with that
[Applause]
and i wish i didn't ask
because he sounded like he was dying to
talk about that [ __ ]
and he had a long story about it and
it's not that i didn't care but i was
you know i don't like talking on the
phone i was watching tv at the same time
so i just wasn't really paying attention
like i should but i was trying to sound
supportive i didn't really know what to
say so i just like mumbling [ __ ]
throughout this conversation i was just
like oh you know [ __ ] you gay man
you're just gay
this went on for a while and then
finally i had to say something like
definitive to get them off the phone and
i was like hey man you know what don't
let people get you down all right and uh
the next time someone tries to make you
feel bad about yourself just remember
everybody [ __ ] funny to somebody
he didn't like that [ __ ]
he's like what the [ __ ] does that mean i
said huh
he said you saying that [ __ ] funny
[ __ ] i said no that's not what
i'm saying i'm saying everybody's
different he said you ain't say
different [ __ ] you say it's you say it
funny what's so [ __ ] funny about the
way i [ __ ] and i said hey man
i [ __ ] feet he said what
that [ __ ] made him laugh
the next day
after the show i saw him backstage he
was like yo what's up man i'm like oh
[ __ ] what's going on and he has his
buddy with him he goes dave unless you
meet man well man where's my fiance
we're in new york getting married
because it's legal here i said oh
oh well uh
that's yes and he went to go get some
drinks
and then my buddy looked at me he was
like so dave
what do you think
and i started mumbling again hey [ __ ]
you know just gang uh
see i'm a little nervous about getting
married man it's a big step so yeah it
is big step
he said well you've been married for a
while
you got any advice for us
no i'm married to a woman sorry about
that
and then corrected me he said no
you married the person that you love
so it's essentially the same
i said you know man uh the problem with
that statement is that it makes the
assumption that i love
but
you guys lighten the [ __ ] up of course i
love my wife
she laughs at this [ __ ] as a matter of
fact she eats and spins this [ __ ]
you know what i told him i told i told
him i said you know what you should do
man first of all you should you
shouldn't do it
uh i'm talking about being legally
married it's not that you're gay as much
as just legal marriage is a [ __ ]
diabolical leverage game in the united
states
i'm just being honest devoid of
religious significance or the idea of
love marriage is nothing but an awful
contract that you shouldn't sign
and just being real
because you start out loving each other
and then like two years later you're
just building a case against one another
for a hypothetical court date that may
or may not ever happen
you know being gay on top of that that
[ __ ] is explosive
[Music]
[Music]
you remember on my podcast you railed
for about 30 hilarious minutes against
marriage like the most persuasive
never get married it's a racket they're
gonna take half your [ __ ]
that lie but at this point no that's
true and i maintain that
it is
an absolutely
insane thing to do yes gay or straight
they used to have no idea what they're
walking into i can't
wait i don't i don't wish this on
anybody but when the gay divorces start
coming in
they're really going to step back i
think being like what the hell did were
we wishing for here
you know
i could have sent him a card on his
deathbed i didn't
really wasn't worth that because they
that was a big thing i can't go and say
goodbye when they're dying but uh that's
if you make it
but it's literally like as far as
marriage is working that's like the
sperm making it to the egg
yeah you're saying dude it's facts
most of them don't work
then you gotta start all over again just
bust it you know yeah i don't know how
it's gonna work
with because it usually sides for the
women but when you got two dudes like
how's how is that going to work out
right
you know what i'm saying i guess it
works out for whoever's making more
money
this is classic like how i talk on the
podcast i just get into it and i'll be
like oh hey i'm a [ __ ] and i didn't
read up on this
how is that going to work out well
guys
it's going to work
the gay dude who's not doing [ __ ]
is going to get all the stuff and be
like oh i'm used to a certain lifestyle
right
and then the gay guy who's killing it
he's gonna go back to the studio
apartment calling it right now calling
it right now
it's gonna be horrible so you're gonna
be great it'll bring straights and gays
closer together just start like a
divorce
bar like all people welcome
and just compare notes like what's more
horrific
a bitter ex dude or a bitter ex woman
yeah when they wrote that hell hath no
fury like a woman's corn there weren't
as many public gay relationships so
maybe maybe that's real bad too yeah but
they didn't have the right to try
not being married they didn't have a
legal contract right so i think what
that when they broke up was probably
whoever was stronger
you know they just sort of wrestled
stuff
you guys are taking this really
seriously
does he really think that's how gay
people break up i'm just messing around
he introduced me as a comedian right
am i gonna have to go on split screen
with a blogger tomorrow
comedy can it go too far
the other day at the pete holm show
i'm right there with you i have to think
that's a feature of a gay relationship
is there would be more wrestling to
settle things
oh yeah
no but is that like
is that spousal abuse or did you just
get your ass kicked
you know what i mean
i do know what you mean
you just lost bro is there less punching
of walls right above heads
in those relationships
very dark i'm with you that's funny you
gotta go with the liver shot
at work
your crohn's are feeding me it's your
fault